Andrew Tate is actually going to be
suing his accusers in his human
trafficking case it is going to be very
interesting to see how the feminists and
leftists will still say that Andrew Tate
is guilty after six months of looking
for evidence
six months he's on house arrest they
have gone through everybody just looking
for anything
and this shows the problem in society
that women really have no repercussions
for falsely accusing men of crimes so it
would be interesting to see if more men
would sue their accusers for falsely
accusing them of a crime we have seen
men get kicked out of colleges get fired
from jobs and really have their entire
reputation ruined all because a woman
was spited
foreign